[Music]
welcome back it's not just new york
because michigan governor gretchen
whitmer is also
facing intense scrutiny for her handling
of covet 19 in nursing homes
and family members are demanding answers
including our next guest
who lost her mother jamie nicholson is
here now to share her story
jamie thank you for joining us i'm so
sorry um to talk to you under these
circumstances but we appreciate you
giving us your time and sharing your
story
thank you jylen let's talk about your
mother nancy
um i know that she was 76 when she
passed away i know that you cared for
her tremendously
at great length for 16 years after she
was diagnosed with alzheimer's
tell me what happened there last year
thank you jillian dad and i worked
so hard and loved mom so much in caring
for her
and on march 11th the
of last year at mom's nursing home
locked us out
dad and i were prohibited from any
physical contact with mom for 11 months
in the final month of her life she was
faced with even more
restrictions moved to a different
facility
and finally died of depression and
loneliness
we watched her over 11 months fade away
and die
through a window and on screens
my heart breaks for you what was the the
best thing about your mother tell me
about her
mom uh had a vibrant personality
even though she was in her different
facilities dependent
fully dependent on care for the last
three years of her life everyone around
her
remarked at her smile her
energy her laughter i would take her
dancing in her wheelchair
and swing it around and play music i'd
clear out all the
the chairs and tables in the cafeteria
and put on the 50s
and she would just light up and and hold
my hand and
and dad would come and hold her hand and
watch
their favorite shows together even when
she was institutionalized
because he loved her so much sounds like
a beautiful woman and you sound like a
beautiful family
i'm going to keep you here with us i'm
going to bring in ted goodman who's a
spokesman for
michigan's republican party you know ted
i know lawmakers are requesting an
investigation of what happened here and
and governor whitmer's handling of this
pandemic
can you tell me a little bit about where
you stand on this and how you're trying
to go about getting answers
sure uh and of course uh our hearts go
out
uh to the family and and all the loved
ones we've lost over the course of this
pandemic
such a heartbreaking story we just heard
and this story is playing out
repeatedly across the state of michigan
and in many parts of this country
so macomb county prosecutor pete lecito
announced yesterday at a press
conference that he is
looking for individuals who may have
lost loved ones inside nursing homes
and assisted care facilities to file a
police report
with macomb county police because the
hipaa laws
do not allow the prosecutor to gain
access the information he needs
to find out the truth about these
nursing home policies
and what happened that may have led to
unnecessary
and avoidable deaths jamie has it been
hard for you to to watch the the fight
that's been going on
in new york and certainly i mean look
all of the attention
is warranted and deserved in new york in
michigan wherever else this could have
happened throughout this country
for families to be able to get answers
but a lot of the focus the last you know
few months has been on new york and just
now
we're talking about michigan do you feel
like you're a step forward now and
trying to get answers
we a dad and i talk about this regularly
jillian and it's hard we you know it's
hard for us to turn on the tv dad hasn't
even looked at the cards that have come
in the mail
with sympathy but let me tell you it
also
strengthens our resolve another thing
about mom was she was a fighter
and that's something that i inherited
from her
and learned from her and and i am ready
i was
talking with senator jim runstad and
he encouraged me to to gather our forces
and mobilize people as much as we could
we
we came up with this group on facebook
like the parents of
athletes who organized 30 000 people and
and got on the steps of the capitol and
had a rally and
and then shortly thereafter uh the
governor
changed her policies and allowed those
uh
individuals and so we want to do that
too we have our facebook
book group called save our seniors
michigan and
we are organizing and we are in this
fight together so that nobody has to go
through
what we did absolutely well we do know
that governor whitmer stands by the
nursing home policy we know that that
she had ended that practice after the
first six months of the pandemic but
still i mean there are a lot of people
just like yourself
who want answers to these questions um
we appreciate you both joining us
that's all the time we have a ted
goodman and jamie nicholson thank you
very much i'm sorry for your loss jamie
we'll be right back